hello i'm charles can turn the chief
scientific officer of sequeira and i'm
going to talk to you today about how we
use human genome sequence information to
try to improve medical care now I call
this subject non-invasive personalized
genomics because as you'll see we use
our extensive amounts of human genome
sequence information in order to draw a
medically useful conclusions give you an
outline of what I'm going to describe
today I'm going to give you some
background on the current status of
human genome sequence information and
give you a brief introduction to
motivate why we do the kind of non
invasive testing that all this God and
then I'll show you detailed examples in
two areas in non-invasive prenatal
testing which is a mature commercial
product and in non-invasive
characterization of cancer which is
still a research tool so it's ten years
or more since we've had complete genome
sequence information and it's fair to
ask how useful this is and the answer is
complex it's extremely useful in a few
diseases like cancer and in prenatal
testing and it's not useful in rows
complex diseases and in a few minutes
I'll show you why that is well the cost
of human genome sequencing is dropping a
substantially every you and soon it's
probably going to be possible to
determine a complete human exone if not
a computer complete human genome
sequence for
essentially trivial cost and we have to
ask several questions as we view that
future is it going to be useful what's
the impact that it's going to have on a
various aspects of medicine including
diagnostics and therapy and let's start
with down once we have everybody
sequence is there going to be any future
left for being a diagnostic test and i'm
going to show you in this talk that
there is a very rosy future for DNA
diagnostics but in aspects that may
surprise you so we don't have a hundred
dollar genome today but it's possible to
have inexpensive test that characterize
a substantial fraction awards you know
for example there's a test available
from a company 23andme and and so what
do you learn if you have a test like
this done today well the first person i
know that had this test this marquis who
was that an alumina and moncler that he
was asian and that's about all he learn
so why is this well we'll a
hundred-dollar complete genome or
complete exome sequence be be more
informative than 23andme answers depends
what you're interested in so if the more
detailed sequence information we have
about a person the more accurately we
construct we can reconstruct their
ancestors and if the person has a very
serious single gene Mendelian disease
the sequence will reveal that and if
they have an unknown disease it will be
tremendously informative but in most
cases a person who has this serious
single gene disease already knows it
because most of these diseases have a
dramatic phenotypes
our problem is that for all but simple
diseases we're not very good today at
predicting disease susceptibility or the
particular phenotypes associated with
the disease from pure genome sequence
okay now there's an exception the
exception as age-related macular
degeneration which is the largest cause
of blindness and all people because
although that initially was viewed as a
complex disease it turns out that only
five genes really dominate most of this
disease and we know a a small number
something like 13 genetic variations
that are common in the population that
give us a pretty good predictive value
of a person's risk of developing the
blindness that associates with this
disease over time but this was the
exception if you like this is the poster
child of whole genome analysis and most
other complex diseases are truly complex
and the number of genes involved is
simply staggering and frankly this is
beyond our computational and perhaps
even beyond our intellectual ability is
disentangle what's going on in the pure
genetics of complex diseases and the
reason is not only are many genes
involved but the environment involved
the environment is involved as well now
most phenotypic traits in humans are
roughly half genetic and half
environmental and we know this because
we have twins fairly frequently in the
human population and we have monozygotic
twins which are genetically identical
and we have dizygotic twins which are
half genetically identical and if we
look at disease susceptibility in pairs
of monozygotic and dizygotic twins we
can calculate a reasonable estimate for
ability that is the fraction of the
phenotype that depends on the genotype
but I'm telling you in an average
situation it's about fifty percent now
we don't really have any way to change
the genetics today and so one of my
recommendations in this talk is that if
you're interested in developing drugs
you're best off to concentrate on
environmental risk factors rather than
genetic risk factors until we have
either more advanced methods of drug
discovery or we actually have gene
therapy well it is possible to unravel
the genetics of complex disease and this
has been done in large studies in a
number of major diseases but the results
as I've already hinted have been
somewhat disappointing they honestly
haven't been that useful to make these
studies better and more useful we need
even larger studies and it's not clear
where the funding for those larger
studies perhaps hundreds of thousands of
patients will come from because it's not
clear they'll be commercially useful
outcome and one of the problems you is
if disease is really not a good endpoint
for most complex disease we need
molecular phenotypes we need phenotypes
closer to the disease mechanism and in
the rare cases where those molecular
phenotypes of them used the picture
becomes clearer but in the end what
we're going to learn I'm afraid is in
each major diseases tens or hundreds of
different diseases and so in terms of
their populations Creek we're going to
wind up making major diseases or orphan
diseases and that that's not completely
encouraging for developing simple
therapeutics okay now there are people
i'm sure who think what a wonderful
commercial opportunity it will be where
we can sequence everybody and
expensively but it turns out that that
attitude is actually pretty
short-sighted the reason is that you
only have to measure the genome sequence
once in a lifetime it never changes and
once we know parental genome sequences
we can predict the genome sequences of
their children with great accuracy
because all we have to determine is the
meiotic recombination break points which
is a far simpler test to determining the
whole genome sequence and the genome
with rare exception is mostly decided
every cell so I honestly don't think
that a 100-dollar genome sequencing is a
long-term sustainable commercial
opportunity so what then is the future
of DNA sequencing well the ideal
diagnostic test has to be repeated often
and fortunately we have many examples
where it's clear it's going to be
medically useful to repeatedly sequence
portions or even entire genomes during a
patient's lifetime so here's a list it
gets complicated and I'll go through it
quickly remember that in mammals we have
five DNA bases not four and five methyl
see what we have six hydroxymethyl see
as well these modified seeds are very
important they're different in every
tissue they change during the lifetime
they have enormous predictive value for
gene activity and so every genetic
measurements are valuable as a signature
of how the genome is interacting with
the environment and in the future I
suspect we're going to want to
characterize epigenetics often the
challenge is that it's different in
every tissue and so it's not clear what
tissues we can access easily that will
represent of the clinically important
epigenetic variables gene expression in
some ways there's a mirror of
epigenetics it has high dynamic range
and but honestly our experience at sea
trying to measure RNA in clinical
samples in a real clinical laboratory is
challenging and requires a very strict
adherence to operating procedures
metagenomics is the non human component
of DNA and most of our DNA is not human
it's bacterial or other microorganisms
and that also changes constantly as a
result of the environment and it's very
useful but it's so very expensive to
measure in addition in some cells the
drum line is not constant so in cancer
somatic mutations occur as you'll see
later and these determine the properties
of tumor and in the immune system of
course there are DNA rearrangements so
before I proceed into more detail let me
just remind you that i'll take question
and answers during you can submit
questions during the talk of
electronically but i'll answer the
questions at the end of my presentation
okay so what I'm suggesting is that
instead of focusing on using human
genome sequence information to explore
genetic risk we instead use it to
explore coupling between the environment
and the genome and focus on signs of
disease onset progression minimal
residual disease disease recurrent and
also focus on the one thing that turns
out to be relatively simple which is the
genetics of drug response so
pharmacogenetics now sometimes called
pharmacogenomics both in the germline
and somatic tissue is very informative
and and basically is revolutionising
much of how we think about cancer and is
simple
because in most cases the genetics of
how a drug a very small molecule
interacts with its target or the enzymes
that metabolizes in most cases those
variables are genetically simple the
other area that I think we should focus
on is biomarkers which are
characteristic to either disease in a
tissue or the disease process and that
latter focus will be when I concentrate
on in the remainder of this talk so
biomarkers can be anything that you can
measure in a patient but i prefer DNA
for several reasons it's turns out that
it's fundamental to the disease process
it's very stable in clinical samples and
we have pcr which means that every
sample and every target more or less can
be approached with a common protocol and
this is extremely convenient and it's
just not available for any other kind of
biomarker so its acronym we focus not
exclusively but mostly on DNA so my goal
is to get clinically useful DNA samples
from patients without hurting them and I
think the advantages of being able to do
non invasive testing the managers are
compelling the most important advantage
is you can repeat the tests as often as
you right here and the patient is not
likely to complain so you can get DNA
from a variety of sources in the body
but blood is the most commonly used for
a variety of reasons that I think are at
least today pretty obvious so to
motivate you to try to think about why
blood is such a good source for
biomarkers let me pose when at first
might seem to be a very peculiar
question what do Alzheimer's disease
cancer and pregnancy
have in common in all three cases we
have a chance I think of finding DNA
biomarkers in the blood and the reason
it because in all these situations and
many other clinical situations cells die
this primarily happens by apoptosis and
when they die they release small DNA
fragments into the circulation the
release DNA is relatively stable at
least in pregnancy it has about a
15-minute half-life and as long as there
are differences between the DNA that
come from a fetus or an Alzheimer's
brain or a tumor as long as there are
differences between those DNA and the
DNA is from that normally populate blood
which come from broken white blood cells
and endothelial cells we can
characterize those differences and infer
properties of a tumor the brain or a
fetus without touching it and these can
be DNA sequence differences they can be
copy number differences or they can be
at the genetic differences but we have
one pump and it's the problem that's
compromised of these attempts to do
non-invasive characterization of DNA in
the past the DNA is different in the
blood in those clinical settings but
there's not very much of the different
DNA and in fact they're so little that
we run into a basic problem of physics
called stochastic noise so if you have
less than a few hundred molecules of
analyte then it turns out that it's
impossible to precisely quantify how
many molecules you have because of
statistical fluctuations and if you have
10 molecules or less you may miss a rare
sequence or otherwise informative DNA
fragment all together just by
fluctuations and
this means that the sample handling has
to be a very good so that you don't lose
any a delight and also means that it's
critical to have a way to qualify the
samples as I'll show you later on at
least in one case because we have to
make sure there is analyte in the sample
otherwise we just get false negatives so
what makes this problem worse is that
different individuals have very
different amounts of DNA in their blood
either normally or in pregnancy your
disease and we don't know why so in
pregnant women commonly in the
population we see a 20-fold ring in the
amounts of people yelling and in cancer
patients we see at least 100-fold ring
and the amount of term specifc DNA in
the blood and the reasons for this
remain mysterious conspired many
attempts to decipher them so to do
reliable qualitative measurements and to
do any quantitative measurements on DNA
molecules and blood we have to overcome
stochastic noise and there are two ways
to do this the easiest one is to repeat
the measurement and if you repeat the
measurements then you can improve the
signal to noise by luvely the square
root of the number of measurements you
make so if you repeat a hundred
measurements then you can improve the
signal to noise by a factor of ten but
our DNA measurements consume the sample
so if I require a 10 mil blood sample
for a single measurement than 400
measurements I require a liter of blood
and that's impossible okay so I can't do
that not in the real world my
alternative is to try to combine result
from different but biologically
equivalent markers so for example if I'm
looking at a chromosomal and employed
any sequences that come from the same
chromosome or equivalent
because they allow me in the same way to
count chromosomes and in a much more
sophisticated way i can use haplotype
information to try to combine
measurements from a region origin rather
than have to make a direct single gene
measurement and I can improve my signal
to noise that way substantially so very
briefly let me show you the status of
three potential areas where a
non-invasive measurements of DNA and
plasma appear to be useful so in
prenatal Diagnostics this is a
commercially available product from
several companies in the United States
including secret oh we can test for
common at employees as you'll see we can
test for recess T and compatibility and
in the future this approach is going to
expand to microdeletion syndromes and to
clinically actionable single gene
disorders to mammalian disorders in fact
it's possible to reconstruct the entire
genome sequence of an unborn fetus but
this is still too expensive to be used
in routine practice but as sequencing
costs dots it's going to become feasible
and these methods use generally known or
inferred haplotype information be
average results in regions of the genome
so this is a mature commercial product
non invasive cancer testing is a
research tool but it looks extremely
promising I predict within a few years
it will become common in clinical
practice the current focus is on somatic
mutations that tumor is sensitive to
resist or resistant to drugs and I'll
show you some examples of this what's
usually done in this case it's to start
with a patient biopsy of the tumor and
characterizing the tail sequence
abnormalities of that individual
patient's tumor and then choose glaring
abnormalities to study
in more detail in successive
measurements from blood and once again
for detection individual markers can
suffice in those cases were your cancer
is abundant cancer DNA and blood is
abundant but otherwise we need to
aggregate results for multiple markers
other diseases are just a dream at the
moment but I in neurodegenerative
diseases massive cell death and the
brain in autoimmune disease inflammatory
disease cardiovascular disease
transplant rejection all of this seems
feasible it's just that in these cases
of them there probably are no sequence
differences in DNA that comes from the
target tissue so one will have to use
epigenetics instead of sequence credits
feasible okay so the focus of the rest
of this talk is not on methodology but
on results but just before I get there
how do you do these measurements well it
depends on the complexity of the
measurement if you need massive amounts
of genome sequence information you have
to do contemporary genome sequencing if
you need information on tens or hundreds
of low side but not more DNA mass
spectrometry which I'll show you a bit
of in this talk is useful and if you're
just interested in a single locus then
PCR is fun the relative considerations
among these three methods are you need
to quantify or not every aids cost time
and the major disadvantage of DNA
sequencing at present seems to be the
enormous amount of data processing
that's needed to handle results of the
typical clinical study ok so we
transition now to non-invasive prenatal
tests as I mentioned and as you'll see
this is a commercial commercial product
in widespread use in the United States
the procedure is to draw one or more
10cc samples of maternal blood from this
Sequenom we isolate four cc's of
and we're going to use random shotgun
sequencing to characterize the DNA
fragments in blood and compare the
sequence of these fragments with a
genome assembly very straightforward but
a lot of data now an average pregnancy
it turns out is thirteen percent fetal
DNA in eighty-seven percent from the
mother but as I've mentioned already
there's almost a 20-fold range in the
fraction of DNA that's fatally derived
and so we must have a control to ensure
that there's sufficient data people be
an aid to detect rates of interest we
have to qualify the sample as I
mentioned otherwise we may erroneously
conclude that the fetus is female
because the mother's female and that the
fetus is normal because the mothers
normal in other words we have a
significant risk of file false negatives
now for male fetuses we can use y
chromosomal sequences because the
mother's female she doesn't have a Y
chromosome but half of all fetuses are
email and we can't use that trick and so
in fact the actual method that we rely
on currently is epigenetic signatures we
look for DNA sequences that are
methylated in the fetus but not in the
mother these are imprinted sequences
whose methylation is necessary for
proper fetal development so there are a
variety of methods that one could use
but this shows what we actually do we
search in the genome for sequences that
are methylated in the fetus unmethylated
in the mother and then form in the
recognition pattern restriction enzymes
than a methylation sensitive so that
when we then take the mixture of
maternal and fetal DNA from a pregnant
woman and digest through the section
enzymes we can destroy the
DNA show here in the open circles and
just preserve the fetal DNA in the dark
circles and when we quantify that by a
competitive pcr and detective products
by mass spectrometry we have a very good
way of estimating the amount of fetal
DNA now in practice we do this for
several different methylated regions
with a bunch of internal controls but
i'm going to show you just what one of
these imprinted regions looks like to
convince you that this is a very clean
and powerful method of qualifying the
samples so this is one methylated
sequence that as you can see in women
who are not pregnant there's no
methylated DNA in pregnant women there's
a significant signal from methylated DNA
we can detect even before eight weeks
and beyond eight weeks it's a fairly
robust signal but I want to point out
two things enormous variability from
individual to individual and look at the
scale this is the number of molecules of
that sequence in our plasma sample and
it's a hundred and forty models okay so
we are in the domain of stochastic noise
and we need to use the methods I
described at least in principle to try
to compensate for some of that sarcastic
noise to get good quantitative accuracy
so I'll focus a bit on trisomy 21
because it's the most common of fetal
aneuploidy but the methods are general
to any kind of copy number abnormality
in a fetus here's a cartoon of a sample
of the mother's blood and I colored the
fetal sequences red and the maternal
sequences blue but in reality with
current a single-pass sequencing on
these fragments we don't have enough
accuracy to tell the difference between
the mother and the fetus all we can do
is look at the sequence and try to
assign it to a chromosome so this
cartoon shows the experiment that we do
in routine non-invasive prenatal
diagnostics from the mother's blood we
sequence fragments from one end randomly
we sequence 10 to 15 million such
fragments and we use these to build up
the relative distribution of sorry the
relative just let's try this again I'm
afraid we have to let this click the
light no way to speed it up here we're
going to build up the relative
distribution of fragments from each
chromosome in the mother's blood and
your intuition should correctly tell you
that if the fragments come from a large
chromosome they'll be relatively many of
them if the fragments come from a small
chromosome they'll be relatively few and
some of these fragments come from the
fetus and some come from the mother but
we can't tell the difference so in the
end we have a plot of the relative
abundance of fragments of each
chromosome and that's all we get out of
this measurement if we focus on a single
chromosome if the fetus is normal then
we expect to see a certain number of
fragments proportional to the size of
that chromosome but if the fetus is
abnormal then there'll be extra
fragments more than we expect to see
because the fetus will contribute too
much the mother is normal presumably so
she does not contribute too much but the
fetus does okay so too
this test was useful with women's and
infants hospital in Rhode Island we
performed a clinical trial of about
2,000 patients at high risk for
chromosomal aneuploidy s and this shows
the results of that trial for the three
common try something's trisomy 21
trisomy 13 and trisomy 18 in each place
in each case what I'm plotting is a
measure of the statistical normality or
deviations from normality of the
representation of fragments of those
chromosomes as a fraction of the
independently measured percentage of DNA
fragments in the mother's blood that
come from the fetus and as expected the
pregnancies in which there's a lot of
people DNA have very robust signals I'm
the fragments from pregnancies in which
there's very little people began a very
weak signals we effectively use a
cut-off of 4% fetal DNA if a woman has
less than that we won't do an analysis
and that means that we have to reject
about 1% of the samples but it means we
can get definitive results on 99 percent
and you can see by and large that
there's an excellent discrimination in
each case between the roughly Gaussian
distribution of normal fetuses and the
over-represented samples from unemployed
so when this data was analyzed blindly
the performance was extremely good the
tests are not perfect but they're very
close to perfect the with specificities
and sensitivities usually in excess of
ninety nine percent that original
clinical trial looked at the three
common trisomies it's been extended to
twins and triplets to do a gender
determination and to do the common XY at
employees and the current commercial
product
has available all this information
whether parents wish to get gender
information is of course optional so
this shows up as of three or four months
ago the status of our commercial
clinical tests which was independently
developed by our clear lab based on the
results of those of our clinical trials
this is roughly a hundred thousand of
patients for roughly testing patients at
the rate of about a hundred thousand
hundred fifty thousand a year now and
the results are really tremendously good
but it's important to understand it even
though this is trying a way more
accurate than almost any other clinical
diagnostic test commercially available
it is not perfect we will make
occasional mistakes false negatives and
patients that have very low percentages
of fetal DNA that's the extremes of
stochastic noise and there's nothing we
can do about that we will also have
occasional false positives and those are
interesting they usually speak to
biological peculiarities in the sample
so there's a phenomenon called confined
placental mosaicism in which the
placenta which is the source of most of
the people DNA that we see is unemployed
but the fetus is normal we'll always get
those wrong if you start out with two
twins one of which is an deployed in one
of which is normal and you look too
early in pregnancy after one has died
the placenta will still represent the
twin that's the over there at least in
part and you'll have a false positive
and we can also have other more
complicated issues but these errors
aside we do very well the one cup
and I want to focus on which shouldn't
have been a surprise to us but they open
is what happens if the mother in
addition to being pregnant has cancer
well then on top of the fetal
contribution in her blood there will be
a tumor contribution in her blood and
let me show you what one of these
patients looks like a large amount of a
parent fetal fashion because we didn't
know there was anything else there um an
indication of trisomy 21 but native
z-scores mean chromosome deletion an
indication of the loss of chromosome 13
in chromosome 18 a fetus with these
characteristics couldn't survive and it
turns out that postpartum this patient
was diagnosed with metastatic carcinoma
here's another case we actually didn't
believe it simply repeated it through
some IDFC results here again is this
mother apparently had a fetus that was
lacking parts of chromosome 21 and 13
had too much 18 but in reality this
mother had invasive angiosarcoma okay so
you begin to see you only use a
discovery tool like sequencing in a
clinical setting we discover not only
what we were looking for but we discover
things that we weren't necessarily
looking for here's such a patient this
shell is the relative abundance of
sequence across part of the genome from
chromosome 7 to the X chromosome and you
can see that in this sample of plasma
I'm a pregnant woman there's too much of
the short arm of chromosome 8 you and
now what we see a case like this that we
see these often we don't know whether
it's an abnormality in the fetus the
mother or both unless it's a
well-characterized clinical phenotype
now we can distinguish between the
mother and the fetus by going back and
looking
but mothers multi-code which is pure
maternal but these are a problem here's
another three cases in which we see too
much or too little of small regions of
chromosomes and we may not be able to
tell whether this has a clinical
implication or not depending on how much
is known before so this is the future as
he's tested Bob you're going to be
getting more and more of detailed
chromosomal information and it's
important that medicine keep up with our
ability to predict the phenotype that
results from these situations now as I
already mentioned we published a two and
a half years ago that it was technically
feasible to work out the complete genome
sequence of an unborn fetus from the
mother's blood that experiment was quite
expensive in the past year two of the
group's repeated it made some
modifications and improvements but this
is far from being routine practice and
that's fortunate because the
implications the ethical and social
implications of being able to know the
entire genome sequence of the fetus
before birth are profound and I think we
need some time as a society to figure
out how best to use this information
before we get flooded with it okay so
that's what I wanted to tell you about
non-invasive prenatal testing and in the
remainder of this top i'm going to show
you the much less mature field of
looking at tumor and i'm going to focus
here on using mass spectrometry although
there's a place in these measurements or
for sequencing and for pcr as well but
in
most tumors there are a relatively small
number of somatic mutations that act as
driver mutations and determine the
properties of the tumor and in many
cases determine the drug sensitivity or
lack thereof of the tumor and the number
of these falls into a range where in
most cases we don't need to do whole
genome sequencing but it's too
complicated for pcr and so DNA mass
spectrometry plays a powerful role here
and what it basically allows us to do is
a highly multiplex pcr and then
simultaneous detection of many many
informatio fragments because unlike
optical of fluorescence detection which
is limited to several analytes in the
state to mass spectrometry because it's
a high-resolution spectrum not a low
resolution spectrum allows a potentially
hundreds of analytes to be analyzed
instead of just a few well I want to
show you just a couple of examples in
the past year they've been many
publications demonstrating the promise
of plasma DNA measurements in following
the course of cancer the first of these
I became aware of came from behind to
bono's group in London and then doing
phase 1 clinical testing so these are
patients with quite advanced cancer and
they were characterizing cancer specific
DNA sequences in plasma and also
comparing to your toolbox so this slide
shows you the amount typical amount of
DNA on average that we measure in
pregnant women here expressed in terms
of mana grams of totally in April and
that the bonus group measured in healthy
volunteers and late-stage cancer
patients the
the Jews were different so I don't think
that this difference between 3.8
nanograms and 7.4 is necessarily
significant ah but the methods used
between these second and third sample
for the same and so the roughly eight
fold increase in the amount of DNA in
late-stage cancer is tremendously
significant and it encourages one to
suppose that most of this extra DNA is
from the tumor itself although that
remains to be proven so this shows the
amount of DNA in various patients as a
function of the type of cancer
colorectal breast melanoma and so on
compared with the healthy volunteers and
you can see that as in pregnancy this is
a log scale handsome pregnancy there's a
tremendous inter patient variation in
the amounts of this DNA and as I've
already mentioned with pregnancy of the
bottom roughly half of these samples are
in a domain where they are compromised
the results are compromised by
stochastic noise the rest or not now de
berault had it the time available
methods for detecting mutations in blood
which or tumor that were about five or
ten percent are sensitive okay so
smaller fractional amounts of beautiful
sequences he couldn't reliably see and
this very complex child shows in many
different types of cancer and many
different aqua gene mutations the
relative concordance of measurements
from plasma and measurements from sample
of the solid tumor and I can tell you
that the concordance on average is
roughly a half and and that's some I
that's probably because of two reasons
the first is that the average are
amounts of these mutant sequences are
low and probably samples where there's a
small amount of mutation are missed
either in the tumor or in the plasma
okay so that's one reason for discourse
but the other reason for discordance is
that there's no reason to think that the
DNA that derives from a tumor measure
directly from a sample of the tumor will
be the same as the DNA that derives from
blood because in blood you're looking at
the cancer cells that have died and in
the tumor sample primarily you're
looking at cancer cells that are alive
okay so we have a ways to go and we're
going to need more sensitive methods
which I'll show you briefly to try to
improve on this but it turns out
curiously enough the just the total
amount of DNA in the patient's blood is
a very good signature of prognosis in
these cancer patients and here patients
who have relatively small amounts of DNA
in their blood seem to have a pretty
good prognosis over a two-year period
risk patients who had the highest
amounts of tumors DNA in their blood had
a very poor prognosis and this was one
particular study but these results have
been seen now in other studies okay so
this is good but what we really want to
do is be able to use these measurements
to help guide therapy or to help better
predict prognosis for individual
patients and so the second example i
want to show you that was recently
published from a japanese group using
DNA mass spectrometry to look at a
famous mutation the t790m mutation in
egfr in lung cancer patients so in lung
cancer mutations in egfr make you a
candidate for certain drugs that inhibit
this tyrosine kinase but patients who
also have this edition
tation t790m are less susceptible to the
drug so the drug is less effective in
these patients so this is a very useful
and the group measured it on a about a
hundred patients and what they found was
in plasma non-invasively they could see
this t790m mutation in a significant
fraction of the patients and those
patients who were t790m positive as
shown in the red curves had relatively
poor prognosis compared with the
patients who were t790m negative so this
is perhaps the first example but example
of many more to come in which
measurements of somatic mutations
non-invasively in plasma I going to
allow us to monitor cancer therapy and
make your choices to keep with switch
drugs depending on the rotation to the
show up but to make these measurements
we need higher sensitive and in fact
these measurements from Japan used a
trick which raised the sensitivity to
better than one percent and I'm going to
show you a new version of that trick
just to let you peek a little bit into
the future this is a tool that we
recently developed at Sequenom called
ultra sensitive detection and it's based
on a very simple principle we have a
huge excess of wild-type sequence we
don't want to see we have a very small
amount of mutant sequence let's say one
percent that's what we want to see this
gives us a tremendous background in the
mass spec so since we're actually
detecting sequencing by synthesis
products after pcr what we do is we
leave out the substrate that can copy
the wild-type template so we have
substrate they're only copies that you
can template that substrate has a biotin
on it and so we can use tip evident to
pull out the molecules that correspond
to the mutant sequence the wild-type
sequence becomes invisible and when we
look in this case by mass spectrometry
we see only a little sequence so
is an example of how well that works in
synthetic experiments for a bunch of
different mutant sequences and process
control to prove this DNA present uh you
can see that one percent hackers and
even forty percent we get good strong
signals 0% we get no I was positive and
our process control shows there's DNA
there so these were just synthetic spike
in samples but clinical sample have now
been studied by the same methods and
this tool looks very promising and
should be available commercially in a
few months them at these very low levels
of DNA sequence detection is possible
but quantification is not because of
stochastic mode now in the last few
minutes of this time I want to show you
an example of where quantification how
much mutant sequence is present it's
tremendously useful but I can't do that
on plasma I have to actually go to a
sample of the tumor to have enough
material to work with so I'm going to
talk for the next minute or two about
telling whether a tumor is homogeneous
or heterogeneous that is whether it's
clone or not so if I have a sample of
tumor it's a mixture of normal and tumor
cells and of all the tumor cells are
identical then what other mutations
idler I should observe in all of them
which means that the allele frequency of
any mutation should be the same because
it's just the percent of tumor cells in
the sample but if I have a Henry genius
tumor we're different tumor cells have
different mutations then this simple
result will not apply so I'm going to
show you some examples of this and lung
cancer samples from a japanese group
these are some famous lung cancer cell
lines just to warm up to this so here's
pc9 cells which have two mutations but
you can see that there
allele frequency is different all of
them have this one but only after them
at that one H 1975 another lung cancer
cell line again three different mutation
frequencies a derivative of P seen on PC
9z d it's a mess okay so most of these
commonly used lung cancer cell lines are
not cold and this shouldn't surprise you
because the way we grow mammalian tissue
culture samples in the laboratory is not
by plating from single cells but by just
illusion so that there's no reason why
these sunlight should be clonal they
just represent the most fit mixture and
the same thing happens in some but not
all rumors so these are lung cancer
patients if you look at patient 88 at
the bottom two different mutations
exactly the same allele frequency
patient 81 the same story but at the top
patient 25 most of them tumor has an
EGFR mutation but the Kos and tp53
mutations are rare so very different
results in different patients more
patients the same idea at the bottom
patient 471 the two mutations are at the
same allele frequency but the next
patient of flora center very different
okay now the reason why this is so
important is that if you have a patient
with a call tumor it's possible that a
monotherapy might work but if you have a
patient with a mixture of different
types of tumor cells then it's clearly
then an effective therapy is likely to
have to be a combination therapy and
this is a very important lesson in
managing the patient but as I said right
now the frustrating thing is if we're
not able to do this from plasma this
requires an actual sample of the truth
okay so very briefly one last case
instead of looking at sequence
differences we can look at methylation
differences this group is frisked
Republic these results two years ago for
breast cancer again using mass
spectrometry
here's a case where in the normal tissue
a particular sequence this is at one of
the bracket jeans is unmethylated as you
can see on the right very little
methylation exists in a sample of the
pure tumor in the center it's almost
fully methylated and in the blood of
this patient you can see that it really
looks like the tumor can not like the
normal tissue this tells you two things
that there is a tumor and that most of
the DNA in the blood comes from the
tumor so the advantage of methylation is
we can derive many many methylation
markers and use them in combination to
try to overcome stochastic noise in this
case Achilles study eight different
markers were used I dwell on the details
but using principal component analysis
they are able to distinguish in blood
with the pretty good reliability the
patients who are normal from the
patients who have blood cancer again
these are non-invasive methylation
measurement of paper blood so this gives
you a peek into the future I like
methylation very much because we're
likely to have such a large number
market markers but admittedly the tools
available today to study methylation are
a little bit more taxing than just to do
sequencing so I'm giving you an overview
of the current state of the art of
non-invasive testing in pregnancy and
cancer and a hint these same methods
should be applicable in a variety of
other diseases that's the end of my talk
and I'd be delighted to try to deal with
some of your questions let me see what
we have here okay so the first question
is why once in a life what about
mutations caused by environmental
changes okay that I guess I chose to
write the answer and also say it well
environmentally cause mutations are rare
and just like epigenetics if they lead
to a disease phenotype as a result of
occurring in a specific tissue we have
to access we must have to access the
specific tissue and that can be very
that can be very difficult so I'm not
saying this is not useful but I'm saying
this is a painful way to make a living
so the second question is do we collect
tissue samples or blood samples and in
in pregnancy blood samples only can
cancer it's nice to have both tumor
blood ok which DNA purification do we
use some whole blood are ok let me
answer that we first make plasma and it
clicked my spelling here ok so that's
straightforward ok the next question is
a very sophisticated one has to do with
that it does the nature of the chromatin
in the cells of affect the efficiency of
producing fragments and the interest is
it does affect it and we're trying to
work that out
okay the next one let me just okay this
is also a very very good question it has
to do with how do we manage to get rid
of that signal to noise to detect
microdeletions and the answer is set
then i'll type it out we have to
sequence much deeper to see these
microdeletions and we have to use
sophisticated certainty we have to use
as a fancy signal processing methods to
get these answers properly okay I think
this one we don't need to answer because
it looks like it's already handled okay
this is a
about Mike mitochondrial DNA if i
understand it right and let me let me
answer that we don't we have no
straightforward way to look at feebly
derive mitochondrial DNA because it's
the same as the it comes from the mother
so it's the same sequence of the moment
this is about the intellectual property
in this area it's a big contest right
now
okay I think I answered oh I see answer
the questions verbally not typed on my
device okay so that I ok let me go back
over some of these a question do I think
direct DNA or RNA purification from
whole blood is desired and my answer is
that is much easier to work with plasma
because when you work directly with
blood it's um you have too much of a
danger of breaking the host cells going
backwards um the question is do I think
a single or a few genes could account
for different tumor metastatic potential
I really haven't talked about metastasis
at all and I have no idea how
complicated that is see if I can I guess
I can't get back to any of the others
okay I
we've answered all the questions and I
thank you anybody still listening for
participating in this and this talk can
provide CME credits so those of you who
want a CME credit should go to this
website and and follow the instructions
once you log in to get your CME credits
I guess I guess that's the end let me
just check into there's any more
questions oh I hear it goes for IP have
I mentioned the answer the IP situation
in the non-invasive prenatal space is
extremely complicated and there's a
great deal of litigation in the cancer
space the IP situation is also
complicated and there's no commercial
product yet so there isn't a great deal
of litigation but they probably will be
in the future okay I think I'm done and
all I need to do is to figure out how to
log off you